los últimos análisis que llegan desde la
capital kéfir también de organizaciones
internacionales que siguen el conflicto
Es que la próxima Gran Batalla en el
este de Ucrania en el don va a serían
esta ciudad donde nos encontramos la
ciudad de durante semanas y meses fue
ese centro de operaciones de las fuerzas
ucranianas para liderar la defensa de
las poblaciones de lisichangs y Cerebro
hoy actualmente esta ciudad podría
quedar convertido en un escenario de
batalla parecido ayer el ministro de
defensa ruso se reunió con los
comandantes militares que dirigen esta
parte este del país lo que hace pensar
que hacia aquí viene la batalla en este
momento los enfrentamientos están
concentrados muy cerca de aquí en la
ciudad de cibers una ciudad mucho más
pequeña y menos importante y estratégica
que lo que es bakmut aquí siguen pasando
artillería hay misiles se detienen en el
aire con estos de antiaéreas sin embargo
las sirenas siguen sonando y quienes
viven aquí dicen que la situación es
bastante difícil hay ataques
constantemente sin embargo un sector de
la población no grande se ha quedado
aquí dicen que es bastante difícil
durante las mañanas salen hacen su
compra y ayuda humanitaria también que
llega desde algunos sectores y ya en la
noche se meten en sus casas porque
suelen ser como fue la de anoche según
nos dicen bastante intensa